starting this hour off with Grand
Junction
Terry is on the line hey Terry what's up
I have a question I'm currently in baby
step 2
I'm almost done with it I owe about
$1,200 left I have my emergency fund my
son passed away last month oh my good
and yeah how old was your son 31 oh I'm
sorry what happened um
I can't say it I'll cry okay um I needed
to find out though I didn't hear it his
retirement and I didn't know if I should
cash out one of his two ones pretty
small if I should catch it out to pay
for the burial stuff or if I should just
try and cashflow it how much was the
funeral
um well I've paid four thousand I have
another about fifteen hundred dollars
left to pay great so you have that
fifteen hundred dollars of debt and you
had how much other debt did you say
twelve hundred okay I'm almost done I
knew I would have been done yeah next
month yeah so $2,700 clears you up and
how much retirement did you inherit
about 23,000 okay and so that's an
inherited IRA now that's going to be
rolled over and what is it are you
single
no um what's your household income about
fifty thousand a year
oh what a heart-wrenching thing to go
through I'm so sorry
um the well mathematically the best
thing to do is to leave the retirement
alone because if as you pull it out
you're going to pay taxes on it
obviously there's an inherited IRA does
not have a penalty but it does have
taxes there's going to be some required
withdrawal on that each year as a part
of the inherited IRA regulation
is the way the structure works on it and
you might find out what that is when you
do the rollover so you may want to go
ahead and pull the amount out that you
have to anyway and then of course what
you got taxes do on that amount and you
know if you wanted to do that that's
okay enough to just knock this out but
you know generally the way I look at it
is it anything any amount of money I can
keep the government's hands off of and
let it grow without them touching it is
a good thing and so I try to minimize
the amount that you pull out and the
good news is that the amount of debt you
have left is small right so you can like
you said you can still knock it out
fairly quickly anyway so what I would
tell you to do is this let's do this do
you have a good mutual fund broker that
helps you with your investing I do okay
sit down with them and ask them to
calculate what you're required to pull
out on this inherited IRA roll it over
to an inherited IRA get it in some good
growth stock mutual funds if you're
required to pull out a thousand dollars
you know you might as well just go ahead
and pull out enough and knock it out
then right but generally speaking let's
say it was $10,000 in debt instead of
2,500 okay I might just say let's cash
flow it and leave this alone because I'd
like for that inherited IRA to just
continue to grow without taxes on being
paid on it right now but if you want to
again a small percentage of the
situation and you're going to pull out
some anyway so get advice on how much
you have to pull out and you know if you
just want to up that just a little bit
and knock this out then I probably would
I'd probably just be done with it partly
because the bill laying there is just a
painful reminder of this whole event
while you're grieving and hurting anyway
ouch
I'm so sorry hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or five hundred
thousand dollar income
you